[موسيقى]
لقد كنت في لشبونة منذ عدة أيام
ولدي اعتراف بأنني أحب
المكان
[موسيقى]
أنا محروم تمامًا من السحر
الذي يسحره الود الذي
أذهلني الجمال والدفء والترحيب
إنها بعيدة كل البعد عن أن تكون هذه
العاصمة الأوروبية المتعبة والبالية التي كنت أخشى
أن لشبونة في منتصف نهضة أخرى
إذا سألت البرتغاليين فلن
يمر وقت طويل قبل أن يذكركوا
بالمستكشفين العظماء وعصر الاكتشاف
و  سوف تنسى بسهولة أن ذلك
كان قبل 500 عام ويطرح السؤال
جيدًا ما الذي فعلته
مؤخرًا وأعتقد أن الكثير من ذلك قد تغير في
العشرين عامًا الماضية هناك روح جديدة من
الثقة وتتطلع إلى المستقبل
هنا يمكنك أن تشعر به
بهذه الثقة  يبدو أنه يأتي من
البلد نفسه البرتغالي الذي
يحتضن الآن هويته الخاصة
[موسيقى]
الآن
الطاهي يبدو وكأنه مطعم لطيف للغاية ،
هل تعرف من يمتلكه
لدي فكرة أنك تفعل الشيف الشهير
جوز أفيليس يعرف كل هذا جيدًا
إنه تشا  تناول الطعام البرتغالي الفاخر
لسنوات ،
لقد طلبت منه إعداد طبق بسيط
يتحدث إلى الحمض النووي العمود
الفقري المعنى الحقيقي لهذا البلد
وهو الشيء الذي أدهشني
خلال المهرجان فقط العدد الهائل من
السردين
وشطائر اللحوم التي أكلتها  يبدو الأمر كما لو أن
هذا جزء من
الثقافة ، كل شيء الحمض النووي ، نعم ، أنا
جميع
السردين عندما يصل السردين ، يبدأ الموسم
هناك في البرتغال ،
يبدأ الصياد في إحضار أول
سمك السردين في ذلك الوقت ويبدأ
المخاوف
[الموسيقى]
عندما  قال لك إننا أردنا منك أن
تصنع السردين ، هل تعتقد أنه
لا بد أن أخبرك شيئًا ما
بالنسبة لنا السردين هو شيء
مميز جدًا لأنه شيء
لدينا فقط ثلاثة أربعة أشهر في السنة
لأنهم أكثر بدانة.
جميلة وهذا شيء
بدأت في تجربته
لتقديم الطعام الفاخر ،
أود أن أقول قبل 15 عامًا ولكن دون
تدمير الجودة الأساسية
لكونه سردين برتغاليًا
كبير هو جوهر كل
ذلك لأنه عندما يصل البرتغالي
إلى
مطعم برتغالي معاصر ، فإنه
يتوقع أن يكون لديه طعام حديث ولكن
لديه روح الطعام البرتغالي ،
لذلك لدينا الكثير من الاحترام
لسمك السردين ، هناك كلمة
ملح الروح هذه نعم ولكن  هناك
كلمة برتغالية للروح ، أليس هناك
ألما جحيم الآن هذه السردين
تنتظر انتباهك ماذا فعلت
معهم ، لقد حصلنا هذا الصباح على
طازج
جدًا بالفعل سمين جدًا ،
أخذنا للتو شرائح الفيليه وتبلنا بالزيتون
الزيت والقليل من الخل ، أنا أحب
السردين ، فهو يعيد ذكريات
العطلات
مع العائلة ،
لذلك لدينا هنا السردين ، نعم ، لقد
تم طهيه قليلاً
مع الحموضة ، فنحن نستخدم الشعلة
لمشاهدة رفعها ،
لذا هنا تبدأ في الحصول على
رائحة السردين
مثيرة
للاهتمام
هذه هي
نسختنا من السردين البرتغالي النموذجي للغاية ويمكنني أن أخبرك
أغمض عينيك أنك تأكل هذا
السردين ولديك كل شيء بشكل جيد  عيناي
مغمضتان ،
فأنت تريد أن تأكله الآن
سأجربه الآن ،
دعنا نذهب
أوه ، إنه مسيء لك لا لا لا ، دعنا
نذهب ،
إنه لذيذ تمامًا
[موسيقى
] ولكنه
طعم أنيق وراق
ولكنه سمك
سردين  السردين لذيذ
إذا اضطررت إلى تلخيص المطبخ البرتغالي
في فلسفتك ،
فماذا
سأقول أن المطبخ البرتغالي
الذي ينتقل من الجدات إلى
الحفيدات من الأمهات إلى البنات
هو فنون
جلب النكهات ببساطة
مع الحب وهذا ما  نحن نحاول القيام بذلك
حتى لو كنت تفعل ذلك بطريقة إبداعية للغاية مع
الكثير من الإبداع ، ما تحتاج إلى تقديمه
لضيوفك ، إنه شيء لذيذ
، وأود أن أقول إن
90 من الوقت
لا يستطيع السردين البسيط وحده أن يشبع حقًا
بالطبع يجب أن يكون هناك برتغالي
الكاسترد دارت ، الحياة دوناتا الباستيل
قصيرة جدًا لعدم تناول الحلوى ، أعدك
أن الحلوى التي فعلتها ، كنت على
حق ، لدينا هنا البيتزا
[موسيقى]
أوه تلك المعجنات خفيفة
جدًا والكاستا
انظر إلى ذلك اللطيف والحازم
ولكن ليس حازمًا جدًا ،
فأنا أحبه
الآن ، هل انتهيت من ذلك ،
كما تعلم ، أنا أتحدث كثيرًا ، يجب أن
نكون حذرين مع الهدر ، لا أريد ،
ألا نستمر في الحديث ،
لا تقلق  عني ،
لشبونة وليمة وأنا جائع لمزيد من
المعلومات
آه ،
شكرًا لك سيدي ،
هناك دائمًا وقت للحصول على
دوناتا باستيل نهائي وإسبريسو
قبل أن أغادر لشبونة مع
صديقي العزيز فيرناندو براسار
الشاعر البرتغالي الشهير قبعة لطيفة للغاية سيدي
في الماضي  لقد تم
إغراء إهداء مدينة لشبونة
حيث طغت عليها
عواصم أوروبية صاخبة بشكل جيد اليوم ،
وهذا سيكون خطأً كبيرًا لأن
لشبونة تتمتع بكل ما هو
متطور من سحر الأناقة وكلها
مغلفة بالضيافة البرتغالية
وهكذا للكلمة التي أعتقد
أنها تصفها بشكل أفضل
ألما
الروح
لقد سمعناها تقول مرارًا
وتكرارًا وستريد المجيء إلى لشبونة
وتجربة هذه الروح بنفسك.